kay is with us in Massachusetts hi Kate
welcome today Ramsey show oh thank you
so much for taking my call sure what's
up um so we're new to the whole damn
Dave Ramsey way of life so we're just
starting number two and my question is
our credit cards are in collections we
haven't made payments on them not even
minimums so how I have them listed
smallest
how many of them are they are there that
are in collections right now there's two
veteran collections and art you've not
paid any payments on them for how long
honestly I think like two years okay
don't put those in your debt snowball
okay is that the only thing that you're
that far behind on um yes sir and we
have other debt but that's what you're
current on yeah you're paying payments
on it you're current on it okay so you
work your normal debt snowball until
everything is paid off but your home how
much debt do you have not counting the
two credit cards and collections ninety
nope $80,000 and half of that more than
half of that is student loan what's the
other half
okay okay most of that is a student loan
and one of you know eighteen thousand is
a car loan the rest is didn't want
what's your household income our
household income right now is $64,000 a
year my husband works two jobs police
officer and national guard so I would
get rid of the $18,000 car okay it's a
lot of car as broke as y'all are yes sir
yeah yeah it's one-fourth of your debt
and it's um you know it's if everything
was paid off
you could have that much car if you paid
for it but yeah it's it's really a big
chunk of your life how much do you owe
on these credit cards that are in
collections um one is thirteen thousand
and one is six thousand okay when you
get ready to address them there those
are big enough that they're eventually
gonna sue you little ones won't ever get
around to suing good they're eventually
going to sue you know you'll have plenty
of notice when they do sue you you may
have to stop your debt snowball a minute
and pile up some money an old credit
card can usually be settled for
somewhere around a quarter on the dollar
so meaning a four thousand dollar lump
sum settlement offer on a sixteen
thousand dollar two-year-old credit card
two years since it's been paid on will
probably settle that with some arguing
and some haranguing and a bunch of
whining and a bunch of listening to
their crap and all that but at the end
of day if you keep beating on I mean
probably settle it for about a quarter
on the dollar okay okay so at some point
in the process you're gonna save up a
lump sum I'd like for it to be at the
end although you have a pile of debt and
not a lot of income so it's gonna take
you guys a while to dig through this so
I don't know if you're gonna get by with
not dealing with these until all the
other debts gone like I was originally
saying because you've got an it's you
just gonna be there a little while so if
they come at you and sue you
it's not like you have 20 seconds to
come up with the money okay they sue you
you can mess with them for 30 days you
can mess with them for 60 days not
threaten to sue you if they actually do
it they'll threaten for two years before
they get around to it
okay so you can't you listen you could
tell a credit card collector is lying if
his mouth is moving all right so you
can't believe all the bluffs and all the
carrying on and if you're gonna settle
it with them you have to get it in
writing in writing and it cannot they
cannot have electronic access to your
checking account because they'll clean
you out so when you do get around to
settling it about a quarter on the
dollar in writing and doing that so if
you're going along in this thing you've
sold the car and you're plowing through
the student loan
and you know you're two years down into
this thing and now it's four years since
you paid on this credit card and they
eventually get around to filing soup you
know you've got some time while you're
doing that to negotiate with them
stop your debt snowball and pile up the
three or four grand and settle with them
on lump sum no payments okay okay that's
how that's how you handle them but you
got to get rid of that car it's killing
you